one of the worst things that I see kind
of dating marriage whatever industry is
the labels that they ascribe to
situations if you're not having a date
night once a week if you're talking
about business if you're they just
insert something they then say it's bad
let's say hypothetically Layla and I
were so busy with work that we did
nothing but work didn't have a meal
together for a month if we both didn't
have a problem with it because it was
the season that we were in other people
might say that's bad what they really
mean is I don't prefer that in which
case I say cool live your life your own
way but don't live mine and if we're
both good with it then there are no
problems and so that's where I feel like
a lot of people get off-roaded because
they adopt someone else's preferences
and ascribe good or bad meaning to their
own circumstance and then say we need to
change something or my girlfriend gets a
date night every Thursday why don't we
have a date night every Thursday because
now the fact that we don't have one is
bad and so for us as long as there's no
discrepancy we're usually good